hey youtubers it's Charlie so we're
gonna remember Carrie Fisher forever but
I wanted to do my top 10 ways I think
that Star Wars should remember her
within the movies Carrie Fisher herself
was a lifelong comedian so I broke this
into my top 5 actual serious ways that I
think they should do it and then my top
5 less serious ways so most of these are
gonna focus on the stuff inside the
movies themselves so number 5 Leigh is
supposed to be huge in both Episode
eight in Episode nine all of Carrie
Fisher's scenes were already shot for
episode eight but obviously they haven't
started shooting Episode nine Kathleen
Kennedy the other Star Wars people said
that she was going to have key scenes in
episode 9 meaning that she was gonna be
really important for this story so I
don't think that they should try to
Franken style edit around outtakes from
previous scenes they've shot with her to
like create new scenes and try to tell
the story of how she leaves the Star
Wars universe like whatever her goodbye
is use a CG Leia if you need to to give
her a real goodbye scene that drive the
story in the characters forward don't
try to cobble something together that
doesn't make any sense
we all understand what's happened
obviously they'll need to address it
somehow but just out of respect for the
actress and the character her death
should have meaning so number four do
not try to shoehorn in digital Leia
throughout the entire movie you saw the
end of rogue one they can do whatever
they want like they literally have the
technology to do whatever they want but
I feel like Kathleen Kennedy and the
other Star Wars producers will be the
first to veto a complete digital Leia
throughout the entire movie just because
it'd be complete perversion of the
technology and her memory use a small
scene early in the film with digital
Leia that becomes a big catalyst for the
resistance as well as kylo ren's
character so the way they described the
resistance in Episode seven is that
they're way smaller than the rebellion
like that small ragtag group you see her
leading is about all they have it's not
like the original trilogy rebellion even
the first order is a much smaller group
of people than the Empire was but during
rogue one there's actually a scene where
a hammerhead Corvette literally Rams one
of the star destroyers into another Star
Destroyer he
this epic scene so why not let Leia go
out like that using a Karelian Corvette
a nice callback to her introduction in
Episode four it's been a long time since
we've seen Leia half any fun have like a
genuine action scene this would be like
a really fitting way for the character
to go out helping her friends helping
the resistance in going out in a blaze
of glory
number three lay her to rest with her
family so a lot of this depends on who
is alive at the end of episode 9 but
let's say that Luke Skywalker passes
away sometime during the trilogy during
Episode eight or Episode nine becomes a
force ghost in the way obi-wan Kenobi
did as he continues to help Rey and give
her guidance on her path but put Leia's
physical remains to rest with Luke's
physical remains in Vader's physical
remains anything that's left obviously
kylo Ren carries Vader's helmet around
but I feel like they wouldn't lay that
to rest with the Skywalker family
remains just because it's not
representative of Anakin Skywalker's
life as Anakin Skywalker it's all about
his time as Darth Vader so that's why
Luke left that behind on Endor you know
this is not who you were you were Anakin
Skywalker and even though the planet
that Han Solo's remains ron was
completely destroyed
I feel like kylo Ren or Leia or someone
would have something to remember him by
they would lay those remains with the
rest of the Skywalker family number two
keep her goodbye meaningful and serious
but also allow some of real-life Carrie
Fisher to bleed into the moment allow
the characters that knew her like the
resistance characters Finn Poe to
remember her in really funny meaningful
ways like you would tell funny stories
and memories about loved ones and
friends at wakes after their passing so
we know a lot about Leia's life during
the original trilogy there aren't that
many characters that remember her that
are still alive today from that period
most of the characters that she's with
now are younger people from the
resistance so they would be remembering
general Leia so I feel like there are a
lot of funny remembrances of general
Leia that we haven't heard before that
they could work into the film and minor
ways the end of Return of the Jedi is
actually a really good example of this
of how you go from a very serious
meaning
full private family tribute where Luke
Skywalker makes a funeral pyre for
Anakin Skywalker as like a final
send-off and then they have the
celebration where he remembers his life
as Anakin not as Darth Vader you know
and like I said he left the Vader helmet
in the armor behind so even though it's
very sad that she's passed away you
allow the characters to remember the
good things about her the happy memories
it will probably be the most cry worthy
moment of the film even the most
hardcore do Bros will be crying in the
theater so number one thing though is
that the death of kylo ren's mother
should be a turning point for his
character I know a lot of you are split
on which direction you like the
character to go like you don't want it
to be a complete retread of Darth Vader
don't you know don't want to see any
kind of redemption for him even though
he's seemingly tried to cut himself off
from the light side of the force by
killing his father the death of his
mother would be such a spiritual crack
in him so you know such like a tremor in
the force that he would either have to
go really crazy or it would have to be a
turning point for him where he finally
goes against Snoke in the way that Darth
Vader saw Luke dying and that was the
turning point for him where he killed
the Emperor so kylo Ren just I can't sit
on the fence forever when your mother
dies it's just like the most serious
most gut-wrenching thing that could
possibly happen in the family so
whatever happens you know whatever way
they choose to treat it everyone's gonna
be crying in and obviously from the
Disney Lucasfilm side of things they are
going to be very serious about it but on
the lighter side of things
top 5 less serious more fun ways to
remember her character number 5
reprogram a droid with all of her sass
k2s Oh style so even though Leia isn't
around the memory of her wit is still
around she had some of the best sass
during the original trilogy looking
forward to lots of Laius ass in episode
8 in episode 9 - number 4 just a montage
of Carrie Fisher as Princess Leia doing
stand-up in a random Cantina the way
Carrie Fisher used to do stand-up when
she would do Comic Con panels a lot of
times people ask her Star Wars questions
of course she's attending conventions
mostly because of her time as Princess
Leia but she would usually use her time
on panels to just talk about funny
things talk about real
contextualized Mental Health she did a
really good job of normalizing mental
health just because people look at
Princess Leia and say oh you have
problems I have problems too maybe it's
not so weird that I'm like this slightly
more funny number three Leia never fully
trained as a Jedi but she is force
sensitive so get for some moments where
she gets to mind-control some
first-order troopers in the way that
Daisy Ridley did during the force
awakens
you know she's force sensitive but she
hasn't trained yet but she can still
mind-control daniel craig's stormtrooper
here if you guys didn't know this was
actually double-oh-seven himself daniel
craig underneath this helmet number two
let her wield a lightsaber in the film
she's actually done it in the comics
before there was like this big one-page
panel like oh my god everybody gets a
lightsaber it was like that Return of
the Jedi
r2 moment to a thousand degrees in
number one there's no way this is gonna
happen but it'd be so amazing if Leia
and Luke could manifest a new force
ability using the fact that they're
twins in their close connection usually
the idea is that multiple Jedi working
together are stronger than one Jedi
alone but they're twins so they already
shared a special biological connection
that had nothing to do with the force so
you would think that that would also
give them some extra force abilities
that normal Jedi wouldn't have let me
know in the comments though how do you
want them to pay tribute to Carrie
Fisher Princess Leia in Episode nine
Carrie Fisher in real life was such a
comedian she was like the first person
to say do not take life too seriously
she actually had her remains carried to
her funeral likely it was a very private
family funeral but her remains were
carried in an urn made to look like a
prozac pill so she was having fun with
people even after she passed away so
when that tone to a lot of you are
talking about Princess Leia spin-off
movie I feel like they should wait till
well after episode nine to do any kind
of Princess Leia treatment but spin-off
films for big characters should only be
told after their story is done being
told in the future and there still is a
lot of future Leia story left to tell
there will be another video later
tonight but feel free to suggest new
Star Wars bonus videos in the comments
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my kylo Ren episode
eight
teaser video you can click here for my
obi-wan Ray theory thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]